welcome to Elden ring Rune roulette
here's how the challenge works I have to
spin a wheel to choose which level is
raised if I am able to level up then I
have to spin the wheel for each
individual level possible no matter what
I am not allowed to reallocate or
re-spin for levels pretty simple to
understand this resulted in one of the
hardest challenges I've ever attempted
with Elden ring with a build that I
would not recommend to anybody this
entire challenge was live streamed here
on this YouTube channel so make sure to
subscribe and turn notifications on so
you don't miss a live stream thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoy
foreign
what is our name
easy
oh
all right guys let's go let's do this we
we are not [ __ ] around today okay we
go hard we go fast
we finish quick just like your sex life
I think I care if I die here I don't
but I will fight you
um
there it is
I can do this
I can do this
no I can't no I can't
I went for the hit instead of the heel
I thought I jumped over it
I can do it though let's freaking go
baby come on
okay I should not go for that
not worth
oh this is it this is the Run
remember when I said I shouldn't do that
I don't even know what's happening I
gotta Focus I gotta Focus
come on Jake
foreign
that was so easy all right you guys said
we can level five times so you guys are
seeing five spins or one spin for all
five levels what do you want to do you
want five spins all right here we go
first level
please go to Vigor go to Vigor go to
Vigor go to vigor
[Applause]
okay
okay
[Applause]
spin number three
I thought it went to mind bro let's go
all right
that's kind of a waste but it's okay
these are all going into different
things
go go go go go all right
there it is guys all right well
excellent excellent I'm debating on
getting the Uchi Katana should I go get
it
it's in that cave are you gonna be using
talents that boost attributes
I mean I probably should right or if you
guys ban that I won't use it
it's up to you though oh we're going as
fast as possible
I'm gonna try and do this challenge
today
get her in a corner
there we go
easy peasy well let's see if we can even
use the Uchi after this please don't let
this be an Arcane build with no Vigor
bro we'll be here for days okay here's
the first spin
damn it
that's fine that's fine it's good for
Ash's War right
okay baby
that's what I'm used to I love strength
let's go all these attributes are going
into whatever they're everywhere man go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
okay I'm cool with that all right all
right okay A little endurance in there
that that's always good right
a little bit more straight okay
strength build chat strength build
go go go
I love how bigger and Arcane are right
next to each other let's go that's huge
for the build
give me the decks let's go okay good
spins
that was a w span guys
he's not easy when you can't just kill
him immediately
all right we got good armor from that
guys that was totally worth it that was
Totes My Goats worth it rip Bozo in the
chat rip Bozo let's do some more spinny
spins
two levels
coming in hot
okay
[Applause]
mostly gotten strength so far I have a
lot of experience in that are we gonna
get our decks
let's go
are we like doing good oh [ __ ] my bad I
didn't turn it on
uh how can I show you like this it tells
you
what the last few spins have been right
there so we just got decks and right
before it was strength but I forgot to
pull it up my bad
foreign
easy peasy baby easy peasy let's go
this is quickly turning into a strength
to build strength and decks
[Applause]
I'm fine with it
oh my God
[Music]
I'm gonna die
oh
we really want arcane
Arcane would be big
endurance all right all right
oh
[Music]
I didn't have any stamina
put These Foolish Ambitions to rest
I don't like spear chat
I'm not a fan of it let's try the katana
this is a lot better
so yep
get strength idiot
I'm kind of peaking right now
although we're not going to be able to
use unsheath in a second
I feel like bleed is pretty good
I wouldn't mind arcane
this is actually becoming a strength
build wait did I pull it up on screen
okay good
[Applause]
inch oh don't throw faith in there bro
that's the first first faith that we've
gotten mind this is okay that this build
is weird
this is just like everything up a little
bit at this point I'm gonna upgrade my
Uchi and use that for a while
got the bleed
okay
foreign
I hate that attack I hate it
I really don't want to die together
please be good spins because this is so
important early game
I will always be good with upgrading our
vigor
stew
you
right now
spin number three
endurance I like it
it's like it once our wants us to have a
good strike build
faith
[Applause]
kind of a Mid Town of a mid it's go
okay uh we got two more spins
in faith again
okay
okay
so we got two Vigor one endurance three
strength and two faith
interesting I like it
I think we definitely need way more like
dexterity to even use Bloodhound Spang
but it would be at a major thing to have
later on
I mean that's one of the best weapons in
the game
question
foreign
Mausoleum to dip the remembrance
that's a good idea too
okay I have to go back that way anyway
I'm actually I think we did
you guys remember when we tried to do a
speed run it took us eight hours and
four and a half of those hours were on
malacath
all right
isn't that dumb one spin number one
mind this is a very interesting build I
would say it's not important more mind
get more mind than vigor
more strength
okay
what does that mean
well we got the flame of frenzy that's
good to have but I do stream on Twitch
sometimes I just stream rocket league
and listen to music and that's it
there's usually like 12 people there or
something unless we have to do another
special stream
just to have never know what's going to
help us today every hour
yeah have you guys heard of becoming a
member it makes you a cool kid at school
make sure to like the stream and become
a member today to join our Discord of
all kinds of fun special activities and
if we get to 250 members I'll do a drug
stream where I'll look like a complete
dump that's in front of you guys I see I
I a lot of streamers do that and I just
don't want to
but
I can't do that personally all right we
got two levels
let's do it people we need one more Dex
to be able to use Bloodhounds Fang
I had to enable myself to be able to
accept gifts
yeah I wonder why that's a thing
I'm a whiskey guy I like whiskey soda
foreign
I mean we got enough strength video game
[Music]
no the camera no oh no oh my God
under my moon
did y'all see her literally disappear
foreign
didn't even get to summon that time
these are some big important spinny
spins chat let's see what we get
that right there is bloodhound's Fang
that's Big W
age
faith
kind of made decks again I think yep
decks again okay good good
faith is becoming more prominent in the
build good endurance is Big endurance is
big for us
[Applause]
those were some good spins
you really can just bully these things
with a blunt weapon hold on Spang Bang
Bang
[Music]
still need a four
we could go buy the four
we need a five
five six and seven are in volcano Manor
foreign
phase two that's good
he's almost dead
run
yikes
oh [ __ ]
stop it
he's doing the thing I'm running away
holy [ __ ]
foreign
eight levels
let's go I'll never be mad with
endurance is that okay because we have
Bloodhounds Fang
don't don't do this to me okay
then upped our damage a bit give me some
health please oh my God okay I mean
that's not awful but
one in endurance one in strength one
index
three in faith
in two in Arcane
ah
die
there we go bigger please be bigger
that's not the worst
not the best either neither is that
give me 18 Vigor please dude
it's not even close man I mean that's
okay ish but man we are the weakest
strength build ever let's get it
I don't want to talk about it
I just got saved by the hill
he like caught me in it
thank you
dude that attack is so fast I can't do
anything about it
night that man that was not worth it at
all why did we do that
one level guys let's see what we get
right here
there's our six can't cuss in a title
unfortunately okay there's our five we
can get a seven across the way here
yep
that's good damage
he also does good damage
you're not round not wrong
thank you
I really can't I can't [ __ ] up here guys
that's an early stage too
[Music]
that's so [ __ ] unlucky
tell me if you guys feel the same
he rolls for way too long he's gonna
start going brazy
foreign
[ __ ] let's go baby
please give me some health
this build is so weird man
endurance
endurance
another endurance
I'm finding it ridiculous that we're
just not getting any vigor
any health it I can't even remember the
last time we got it it's nuts man
didn't hit
that was really close
foreign
that was really good bro oh my God
thanks for the two bucks man
foreign
yes
first try Reichard
let's go
please
upgrade my vigor
please
[Applause]
[Applause]
please don't go to int thank you okay
I'm fine with either one of these I
think it's endurance yep endurance okay
it happened oh my God it happened guys
oh wow
we got one go to endurance go to
endurance go to endurance
literally it's three in the mind okay
let's not die to this lady
excellent
what are the requirements for the blast
when displayed like am I anywhere near
that
okay we got our nine
plus nine just like the start of the
Stream
keep doing that attack I like it I like
it when you keep doing it
oh
man he twisted that [ __ ] around so
quick
you know kind of like that
I rolled a millisecond too early
come on
that boss is so hard when you can't get
hit
wow give me more Health game
stop please
[Applause]
like it it couldn't have been closer
dude it's a fun challenge it's all luck
based
Joe Mama on these nuts okay
nice
three levels guys let's go
don't do it to me again
okay
okay
all right sit on decks sit on decks
[Applause]
I'm so confident I'm not even gonna pick
up my runes
foreign
[Music]
foreign
it's happening
it's happening
I I can't believe it
double double bigger pickup guys
let's go
nice Melina
I went for it
oh curse
no [ __ ] shot
it's just me and him
I'm gonna take the heel we got one more
in the reserve
the [ __ ] was that
go
we [ __ ] traded we got that bro I went
for it I was like I did the first
Bloodhounds finesse and I hit him and
I'm debating like do I do it because
he's gonna hit me and I'm like [ __ ] it
that was [ __ ] awesome
oh wait what's that
no one cares we actually beat morgot at
level 73 that's pretty good I'm not
gonna lie okay
yeah we have to fight sewer Moog do we
not really
Faith bro I mean our faith is actually
decently High well now it's really good
oh
mine what is this what would you guys
consider this at and then we get Arcane
I'm that was awful what is this we have
20 Vigor 22 mind 19 endurance 24
strength 24 decks 14 inch 20 faith and
15 arcane
it's a giga build
watch I don't even care if he starts
hitting me
he literally can't hurt me a little bit
oh
bye bye nothing wrong with white
dog I didn't even hit you yet
just give me a little distance from
why did I just hear a phone
foreign
who cares you know
there it is Blasphemous blade acquired
get a little bit more strength in there
okay okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
the Blasphemous blade
absolutely massive
let's go
foreign
thank you
come on baby
thank you
big
come on
he accepted defeat
y'all see that
he gives you 100K down there that's
pretty cool
all right Dex well this will be good if
we're using the Blasphemous blade I'm
cool with mind
do you guys think that they put this
violinist here because they knew people
were gonna struggle heavy with this as
like a joke
[Music]
okay
this is the back step one
not even close I had a whole foot off
that thing bro
you're
here
there it is ladies and gentlemen [ __ ]
the twin gargoyles I don't want to fight
them
it's a bad boss okay I think this is
fair all right we're still here
I thought I'd hit both at the same time
man
oh
everything staggers me
no no no
I banned the annoying kid in chat and we
did it look at that
all it took was Banning the annoying
[ __ ] chat
okay
next
all we have to do Ronnie's questline to
get Thea's questline where were we on
that we have to get
Finger Slayer blade that's what we need
to do but we have to go talk to Ronnie
to be able to do so
whoa
that was kind of close
okay
foreign
okay let's go get it we're already ready
to go down there
there we go we got the statue
I've never killed him that early
go to endurance
go
we have a weird amount of mind on this
build
okay I'm dead definitely yep there it is
foreign
I was gonna say no way he jumps that
right
I'm using the game's mechanics to my
advantage
there we go where's the torrent lore
you guys want a torrent video you guys
want the music up
here we go really [ __ ] loud by the
way
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God that's [ __ ] awesome
where'd he go
found him
foreign
[Music]
oh God I'm dead it almost killed me
afterward I'm just standing in the Mist
okay here we go
yep arc Arc decks here we go
of course it's not bigger but strength
is good is Arcane good for anything we
have I mean yeah we get better bleed
that's true
the point I think Reichard gives us the
most right
wait I put it on screen right okay sick
dude when I announced that I watched
berserk people were like so you read it
and I said no I watched it and they got
so [ __ ] mad
thank God I had that on
foreign
did y'all see what I just did
don't kill me
no I'm dead bro oh
oh okay run under
roll roll roll
I'm that good all right how many levels
do we got two what here we go
you what
okay we're this randomizer wanted a
strength build all right more bleed it
wants us to have a Bloodhounds Fang
build that's what it wants
never mind that was pretty easy you need
something that I can that I can work
with
it's not that
a lot of you don't may not know this
about me but I don't like the fire giant
fight I consider it one of the worst
fights in the entire game although it
looks incredible
I think fighting the fire giant is just
the worst experience of all time
especially when you get them low Health
after 20 minutes of bucking his ankles
and then he just starts going ape [ __ ]
and I have low enough Health where I'm
literally going to get one shot by
everything
however I'm going to go into this
thinking that it's all my fault it's a
skill issue and I just need to get
better and it's not the fight itself
[Music]
[ __ ]
foreign
just hit the hands
four spinny spins let's go fire Giants
way worse than God's skin Duo
[Applause]
what's new alright here we go
I'm just getting trolled
it is what it is
okay hey
it trolled and then made up for it there
we go honestly W roll
foreign
I've definitely got him stuck there
before
dude Bernal one
what
bernal's a legend
oh he's gone
he has he has to snap him back
nice
that was so big
jump in the air don't do ball [ __ ] you
nose
stop oh my God bro
[ __ ] this boss dude
foreign
come on come on come on come on
[Music]
get him
again I can still get one shot by like
literally anything
we got two spinny spins
let's do it spring all right already a
strength build I can deal with it go go
go go go go go go
I guess you know hey guys you know who
needs figure right who needs it
I'm starting to lose my mind if you
can't tell
wow
that's pretty good
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here
[Music]
I thought I was outside of the swing
seems like a weird time to do that but
all right
[Music]
foreign
foreign
why what
why did that happen
[Music]
foreign
you want
where did the Stagger come from through
two hours of attempts that's the only
stagger we got
where did it come from we do have to
spin the wheel it's been so long I
forgot what we were doing oh well that's
not bigger okay
okay not as good not vigor
[Laughter]
no bigger guys uh yep what's new right
no no no no no no please please please
thank you
I did it too fast please
the worst boss in the game
we got yeah this this is good I'm fine
with faith uh it's not bigger again
endurance [ __ ] it why not man
[Music]
I thought he'd go phase two nope
nice
foreign
yikes bro
where are you going bro
huh
what what is happening right now
oh my God
damn it
I'm super dead
come
on
that's cool
nope
GG [ __ ]
nice
let's go
how many bosses are left we have
placidus ax Moog Melania radagon
eldenbeast what kind of day is it gonna
be
I will not be mad about strength ever
that's cool we need more int
potentially
I can't believe it
oh my God it's a [ __ ] miracle
oh man
what
[Applause]
it's doing a row oh my gosh
I'm not cheating shut up I'm not
cheating Dex is good too nice
the best spins we've had the entire the
entirety of the challenge the best spins
possible
it's just a good it's just a good day
out here
we're having a great day so far this
this means 2023 is gonna be a good year
chat
there we go
Mike ah
there we go purifying Crystal tier
visual sling car Mark seal Beast eye
that's good
no spear got it
10K by the way like what do I think is
the worst boss or one that I thought
would be better and wasn't just a little
distance
yeah yeah
oh
that's not good
yeah he [ __ ] melted
thank you
big
no
this fight cinematically is [ __ ]
awesome
that fight's really cool we kind of
annihilated him though did I put it on
screen okay I did
oh my God it's a day all right we got
the secret medallions for the holidays
I had a stroke ignore that uh let's go
let's [ __ ] go we gotta go
ma'am ma'am stop it
he's the best pvpr in the game
no let me move
finally
there we go
I'm gonna try and not get grabbed chat
it's uh good advice thank you okay we
might get grabbed here in a second
go go
I'm dead
excellent
like a little [ __ ] he is
you guys just see that [ __ ] movement
look at my movement
too good at the game pro dodges
[ __ ]
get on my game
and I killed a bug it's literally harder
than killing that guy One Singular
spinny spin
we can always use more endurance I've
said that from the start
[Music]
come on
mama is mine and mine alone
[ __ ]
is mine and mine alone please
way too greedy
way too greedy this is not good
why am I doing that
what that hit me
get me off the stairs man
he wants me on the stairs
[Music]
[Music]
let's go holy [ __ ] oh let's go yes
how about this day
nice
damn
oh
the Dodge is at the end bro the Dodges
were so good it's been number one
[Applause]
that's okay it's a little painful but
that's okay it'll help us with our bleed
in some some way out there strength
again
strength is I've been our big boy
endurance
I almost did mine again how do I buy
members I'm sorry so dumb it should just
be down below at the bottom of the chat
bro did I already do Arcane yeah I did
we have one more spin oh [ __ ]
35 strength
oh I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
[ __ ]
great run touring
that's why we used it
stop
for the love of God
guys easier said than done in the moment
no no no no no no please please please
yeah run toward him right
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
getting decks Dex is good we will take
decks who Give Me Faith No not int uh
whatever it's a good day out here we at
least have 25 bigger guys
foreign
I thought she already shot a man
no no
no
okay
cheeky
[ __ ]
first try not even a hard boss
he's
I am Melania
blade of mikola
and I have never known defeat
who asked just gotta be a little closer
I'm gonna say this now real quick
and Trey I give you full permission
to time out people or trying to tell me
how to dodge the waterfowl do not tell
me to throw pots
to dodge into it
do any of that [ __ ] I'm telling you
right [ __ ] now don't start
I tried to turn around
blade
no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thing to dodge off the rip there man
[Music]
we're figuring her out
no way
like I said
chicken waterfowl here right yep
I'm crouched
what
dude that made no sense what the [ __ ]
not what I wanted to do
[Music]
for
yep
I'm getting real unlucky here sometimes
that's not good I'm dead
[Music]
knock her out
[Music]
risky should not have done that
hurts Queen
all right it seems like
foreign
[Music]
what is that [ __ ] delay man what the
[ __ ]
yeah as soon as I backed up I knew I'm
dead
my fault
that was our first commodity though
oh my God
my bad
what
no
[Music]
I didn't die
[Music]
so we're just gonna do that again are
you kidding
I am millennia
millennium
damn it
I am Melania
[Music]
no hit first face
[Music]
excuse me
no wow
[Music]
no
[Music]
why
in [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
what I think she bled
why did I do that
is she gonna die this time
nope
what's going on
why does this happen there's your no hit
run right there
what a challenge to do on the first day
of the New Year huh hey guys did you
know that you could always use a [ __ ]
frost pot did you know that did you guys
know you could use a frost pot against
Melania and it'll stop her waterfowl
that we've been dodging consistently and
has nothing to do with the reason we're
dying isn't that [ __ ] crazy that you
can use Frost pots holy [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] insane what incredible new
information that we've been given
wow I got baited I [ __ ] knew it
foreign
yes yes yes yes yes yes
wants to be consumed
I am
[ __ ]
yes I'm getting baited there's the bait
[Music]
not a big deal
now it's a big deal
damn girl calm down what
I do a wall uh
I'm getting
demoralize
[Music]
in the whole position
come on please
it's probably close to that tune
he wanted to
like I said
like come on
what is she doing there
I ran out of stamina because I was
running
don't don't do that
lead please like
whatever
and I'm dead because she's got a
waterfowl
please
[Music]
please
foreign
where is it man
this fight's so dumb
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why does this happen whatever
[Music]
so unfair dude
[Music]
[Music]
I
did it [ __ ] you
subscribe
is this really gonna be a stage one no
waterfowl at all
oh of course I bled you so that means I
can't go to stage two where you could
just pull a waterfowl out of your
[ __ ] butthole right now and kill me
there it was I even [ __ ] called it
bloom again
God
[Music]
or am I tripping y'all see that
it looked like it to me
thank you
[Music]
[ __ ]
foreign
I always fall for it
whatever
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh man wow oh man
my boy this has been hell for you yes it
has I really own that rotten boss fight
who's boss she is she's a [ __ ] yeah
they're tears of joy for sure oh man
let's go
thanks selecco appreciate that too thank
you everybody yeah I'm like kind of a
little bit in shock that it happened I
literally thought it wasn't going to or
I was going to be here for 24 hours five
levels five spinny spins two man Dex
makes a lot of sense for that one nah
you won't give me that right nah no shot
you won't give it to me nah
no way up up up oh we're gonna go three
for mine oh my gosh oh no we're gonna
give you Arcane this [ __ ] didn't give a
[ __ ] we wanted
damn it dude well that wasn't worth it
wow
[Music]
probably should have healed there
okay is Eldon week weak to this
can you [ __ ] off
apparently not
what
no
okay
I need to Lane
I guess I did not Dodge okay yep cool
I don't even know what's going on
foreign
I've died with three times
[ __ ] course
thank you
what
excuse me
what
calm down oh God
did I get a stagger please
oh of course not on Vigor I mean imagine
if we got bigger it not that it matters
anymore
uh but of course we didn't do it what
are the odds we get bigger now oh we did
it happen well this had to [ __ ] and
moan about it and there it is we got it
okay yeah okay you know it doesn't
matter all right uh probably ins nope
it's Dex and strength
endurance okay 31 vigor
30 mind
30 endurance
41 strength
33 decks
20 intelligence 28 faith and 23 Arcane
would you recommend the build
let's pick the ending
guys I bagged a MILF he's like thousands
of years old Isn't that cool drunk
stream is next because we hit 250
members I appreciate that our next goal
is 500 where we'll double every boss in
the game and try and beat it like that
we'll definitely try that hopefully with
a better [ __ ] build than that piece
of [ __ ] we use today I'm gonna go eat
and go to bed
that's my plan and shower because I
smell I can tell and uh I hope you all
have had a fun time here on your first
day of 2023. I know I did happy 2023
what a great way to start the year of
just being a [ __ ] Legend at Elden
ring as we are
um look out for a video on this entire
run I hope it does well or I'm gonna cry
okay bye guys I love you and I will see
you in probably a couple days maybe uh
maybe you know soon okay have a good one
okay bye